hola soy pamela del equipo de khan
academy
así que estás aquí por la hora del
código cierto
eso es fantástico aún puedo recordar mi
primera hora escribiendo código cuando
era una niña pequeña ahora estoy en mi
hora 10.000 de programación y sigue
siendo realmente muy divertido hay
muchas maneras de aprender a codificar y
hay muchas cosas que puedes hacer con
código cómo hacer juegos como pacman
angry birds o minecraft o si te gusta la
ciencia puedes usar la programación para
visualizar la manera en la que trabaja
el universo y ayudar a más personas a
entenderlo mejor si te gusta la medicina
puedes ayudar a los doctores a saber qué
está pasando dentro del cuerpo humano
porque es muy loco podrías hacer robots
como carros que se manejan solos podrías
analizar información puedes hacer sitios
web como kant academy hay muchas cosas
que puedes hacer aquí en caracas de mi
pasar hasta ahora de código aprendiendo
a hacer dibujos generados por
computadora no podemos cubrir tanto en
tan poco tiempo pero esperamos que te
quedes muy emocionado de tu primer
acercamiento del código y quieras ir más
a fondo aquí está lo que vas a hacer en
la siguiente hora primero vas a ver
estas guías paso a paso
son como vídeos donde escribimos código
y hablamos mientras estamos escribir
y puedes ver el resultado del lado
derecho puedes para usarlos igual que un
vídeo incluso mejor que un vídeo porque
puedes editar el código que hemos
escrito y ver qué pasa cuando lo cambias
y luego puedes regresar cuando quieras
continuar recuerda que hay audio así que
asegúrate de tener bocinas o audífonos
cuando lo estés viendo luego harás un
desafío de codificación así es cómo
practicarás lo que acabas de aprender y
ganarás puntos por completarlo haciendo
cada paso hasta que lo termines trata de
completar cada desafío hasta el final
pero si no lo haces y te desesperas no
te preocupes solo continúa con la
siguiente guía paso a paso al final a
los proyectos con formas más libres y
creativas no hay una respuesta correcta
y el punto es solo divertirse mientras
usas lo que aprendiste si esto te toma
más de una hora para nosotros eso está
completamente bien aquí en can academy
creemos que todos deberían aprender a su
propio paso siempre estaremos aquí para
que sigas aprendiendo no importa cuánto
tiempo tome listo para empezar tengamos
una fiesta de código